啊，
罗菲老师你好，
我今天给要介绍一下我的情况，
我今年是32岁，
和丈夫是同龄，
我们结婚了六年，
生有一个四岁的男孩子，
现在我肚子里怀着二胎是五个月，
我现在可能要跟我的丈夫离婚了，
我就想请问一下老师，
我的诉求是想要两个孩子的抚养权，
我跟他有一套共同财产，
名字是我的，
但是是共同所有，
我的诉求是能不能争取到50%，
还是我的50%，
把老大的名字加上去，
就是他50%的那一份改为老大的名字，
这是不是我能争取到的一个最大的一个利益，
还有一个就是说我想在生产前办完这个分手手续，
因为我担心老二出生之后会失去老大的这个抚养权，
就是可能会一人一个嘛，
我这样的这个诉求可不可以达到，
先跟我说说你的自己的情况，
包括你娘家的情况，
我和她都是在体制内工作的，
收入基本上差不多，
然后我的父母在体制内的，
在本地拥有3套房子，
就是经济方面的话还算可以，
应该是优于他们的，
他们是其他城市的，
就是这个城市要比我所在的地方要经济落后不少，
然后的话为什么就是发生，
就是想要。
分手的这个事情主要是两方面问题，
主要的问题就是我的婆婆啊对我及我们家不满意，
她从结婚的时候她就认为她的儿子可以找到更好的，
然后我们结婚之后的话，
也一直对我们的家庭就是指手划脚，
然后因为我个人可能是我家里的条件还可以，
所以就是说话语权还是比较大的，
这个月他退休了，
就开始搞事情了，
我的丈夫从这个月开始对我有挑剔，
比如说呃，
对家用啊以及生活的细节开始对我有所抱怨，
然后亲戚就发生了一件比较可怕的事情，
所以让我想到的要分手，
因为他偷偷的想把孩子就是老大给带回他的老家，
嘴上说是爷爷奶奶想孙子，
但是我不得不怀疑他是不是想要把孩子带走藏起来，
这就是我想，
就是说能够通过法律手段来保证我的一个最大的权利，
我丈夫也是有一定问题的，
她的情绪不稳定，
只要她不跟她的妈妈接触，
她的情绪还算稳定，
工作也能正常进行，
对丈夫在这个角色扮演的我可以说是一般，
但是被像爸爸这个角色，
我觉得他是做的比较好的，
但是她的母亲是一个客观存在，
不可能消失在她的生活当中，
所以她。
时不时的就会情绪不稳定，
时不时的就会来找我一些麻烦，
现在对我来说比较有优势的几点是，
第一他是做过假癌手术的，
嗯，
他是带癌症的一个状态，
第二，
他脾气比较暴躁，
对小孩子有这种精神上就是辱骂，
我是有视频的，
还有一个就是我的老大在出生以来一直都是在我这边养啊，
我父母是出钱出力，
并且他他的爸爸妈妈是没有带过一天的，
基本上没有出过什么，
所以我就想问一下老师，
我怎么处理是对我最好的，
如果你想要两个孩子的抚养权，
肚子里的这个归你是没有问题的，
2岁以内归你是没有任何问题的，
如果大了这个也想归你的话，
你需要去提供以下的证据，
其实这个证据就分为两个方向，
一个方向就是我带孩子，
孩子跟着我会过多么稳定，
多么好，
多么有利于他成长教育的生活。
另一个方向就是孩子的爸爸带孩子，
对孩子会造成哪些方面的伤害，
不利的影响，
其实这就是两个方向，
我们自己这个方向我们需要提供哪些证明呢？
比如说有稳定的这个收入，
然后学历。
啊，
身体上就经济、
学历，
身体时是时间、
精力，
包括将来我对孩子的安排，
比如说有学区房啊，
比如说孩子能够上哪个学校啊，
我对孩子将来的安排，
包括我的父母的经济状况，
我父母的房产状况，
我父母的时间陪伴状况，
包括我父母的健康状况，
包括我父母一直在带孩子的这些证据，
这些都可以作为我的一种优势，
那我该如何就是这些材料以及把它梳理成文字吗？
你这个材料的准备啊，
我建议你要花钱找一个律师来指导你准备，
因为真正到打离婚官司的时候，
有很多他是有效期的嘛，
举个例子啊，
我想要证明我自己身体是很健康的，
那我开了一个类似于体检的报告或者证明的话，
他是营效通的，
你知道吧，
所以这个事情的话，
你最好还是找一个，
呃，
找一个律师指导你去带好的整个思路和方向，
你自己要明白，
一方面是证明这个孩子从孩子出生到现在孩子4岁多，
基本上都是我和我的爸爸在带他，
所以他已经熟悉了我们的这个生活情况啊，
家庭环境啊什么的都已经很熟悉了，
而且也带的很好。
然后另一个方向就是将来我会为这个孩子能付出什么，
我在时间上，
精力上，
教育上。
陪伴上我能够老，
我付出什么，
包括我的爸爸妈妈能够我提供的哪些帮助，
因为你是要争两个孩子的抚养权的，
那你一个人肯定是带不过来的，
你明白吧？
另外一个方向就是证明孩子的爸爸带孩子会给孩子带来哪些伤害，
或者说有哪些不足，
第二他脾气不好，
哎，
就是他辱骂孩子，
打孩子那种特别让人很气愤的那些东西的话，
都留下来作为证据。
还有一个就是他有没有什么不良嗜好呀，
总是什么打游戏呀，
赌呀，
干嘛干嘛的，
有没有这些不良嗜好，
有的话也拍下来啊。
还有就是他跟你闹分手的时候，
那段时间他可能会有如时有一些情绪激动的恶言恶语啊，
就是特别一听就觉得他素质很差呀，
一听就觉得他很low啊，
或者说有一些威胁的话呀什么的，
这些都留下来作为证据。
我的丈夫发微信说因为发生了抢孩子的事情，
我把孩子抢回来了，
然后他就愤然就回老家了，
发微信跟我说会让我付出代价，
让我后悔。
我现在我能想到的一个防范措施是可能他们会来悄悄的把孩子带走，
除了就说让我的身边就是带带的人严加看管，
让幼儿园的老师要第一时间通知我有人要接孩子。
我不知道其他有什么防范措施，
这个是我现在比较嗯紧张的点，
说句难听点的话。
好，
嗯，
如果你已经意识到了，
如果你已经知道他们的动机就是要抢孩子了，
在这种情况下，
我宁可孩子不上幼儿园，
我先把这几年度过了，
为什么呢？
因为这两三年是他们抢孩子意愿最强烈的两三年，
等到他的儿子已经接纳要跟你分开这个事情了，
且他的儿子都在外面找好下家了，
抢孩子的意愿就没有那么强烈。
好的，
我明白了，
谢谢老师，
我们那天看了一个特别极端的案例，
就是现在子思带妈妈真的生不如死，
你们不知道，
我不知道现在社会上有多少子思带妈妈，
就是可能明明法院判了孩子归你，
但是人家婆家老公把孩子抢走了，
藏起来了，
就让你找不见吗？
你真的是生不如死，
因为我现在我都想象一下啊，
那谁把我的孩子藏起来了？
我觉得我也是生不如死，
我以前跟你们说过很多回，
就是在争孩子这件事情上，
你不要依靠谁，
不要寄希望于谁能帮我去争取孩子了，
为什么？
就像这种子私带妈妈，
孩子就算判给你了，
法院判给你了，
她如果把孩子抢走了，
藏起来了，
你能依靠谁呢？
刚才那个姐妹她还想争取孩子的抚养权，
假设啊，
婆婆老公，
假设把孩子要是抱走了。
藏起来了，
藏到农村去了，
你找不见了，
你想这个妈妈她怀着二胎，
肚子里怀着一个，
那不得疯吗？
如果你想确定了，
想好了要跟他分开，
且确定了想好了，
你就怕他们把老大给抱走的话，
那你现在需要做的最重要的事情，
除了说自己养好自己的身体啊，
然后自己生孩子，
这个过程当中一定是娘家人出面，
娘家人在身边啊，
这两三年的时间的话，
就一定是把防范的事情做到极致。